GET HIM GAMES.
THE GAME PLAN DIDN'T GO THEIR
ALL TIMES.
HERE'S HARRIS FOR THREE.HE PAIN
MILTON, TO NIANG, FOR THREE, HE.
EM FLIPS IT TOYOUNG, VANVLEET
TRYING TO SLIP HARDEN, SLIPPING
TO YOUNG, IT'S EXECUTING AND
GARY T T2.
HARRIS, SPIN MOVE TO THE
BASELINE ON THE FADE AND A TOUG
THREE POINTER AS SHOOT.
HARDEN IN THE HARRIS, GRABS THE
DEFLECTION, AND TRENT, JR., HE
53%.
MAXEY COMES BACK THE OTHERGLASS.
>> HARDEN STARTING TO COOK A
WON'T GET IT.
>> ANUNOBY PUGA JUST TRYING
LOB TO EMBIID, A HAMSTRING.
>> NIANG, HIS THIRD THREE OF THE
VANVLEET, EARLY N AND SCORES
ABLE TO TAKE GLASS.LING, NOW THO
THE LANE. GO TO
THE INTO THE LANE.TIE.
JOEL EMBIID WITH 25 BANK, NO.
IT'S UP AND  BACK UP ON THE
REBOUND.
BURIES THE THREE
FROM WAY OUTSIDE!
>> ARE YOU KEMBIID,
REACHES OVER,  TO CENTRE.
BURIES THIS ONE IN GAME THREE,A.
>> CATCH.BY WILL PULL UP, WITH !
INTO T T ON THE
REGULAR SEASON.
D THEM BOTH.
NIANG, AND PHILADELPHIA WILL HE
TRENT, JR. OUTSIDE.GLASS, LAID
FRONT
360, AND HE GETS THE FALL AWAY
JUMPER. . BEFORE, THAT'S
FOR SURE.
THAT WASN'T ANY PART OF THE CALL
THEY MADE AS A ROLLED 360 DEGRE
THEN SOME AND
BUT REVIEW, EMBIID